and Omar time yep that's a frequent
opponent nowadays so you're really
playing that ups ok I'm grooming that
pawn and you'll try to weather the storm
I recently had a really bad position
with that home and in one of those rapid
games huh there that was with f6 but I
don't think that this is such a maybe b5
first I haven't I haven't really checked
that line I mean the more is not exactly
high on the list of stuff that you want
to check but back in 95 is this is
constant problem I am I go if I cancel I
really would take it six so do I have to
move the Queen Quincy 7s prolly stepping
right into stuff maybe are usually I
decline the Smith moral and some maybe
that's really what i should do
especially in those blitz games and
rapid or whatever those some those
shorter time control games that
initiative that white is somehow getting
is some squatter quite an annoyance so
what about this yeah maybe 90 eggs
originally I wanted to take with the pie
but she's got them got that 95 stuff
really coming so do i go to c4 or not
and I'm not sure don't really want to
return that pawn realit so that's bound
to happen there's nothing nothing really
surprising question is where to go on
maybe here you should see five might
come
but so is so he's saying that um ok yeah
okay I see if i take d5 you can um maybe
okay yeah queen geforce very irritating
let's just wow he's really insisting on
completely killing me amazing yeah well
this is kind of what people want to do
in that opening okay let's grab that
stuff pawn takes Knight a5 I might be
losing but can also play Knight e5 after
chantix okay here it's easy at least to
play a move I mean not quite sure about
what happens but at least I know I have
to click heading in the corner huh am I
really losing here might be but maybe it
holds
i'll probably go nitey five very soon
even if it gives away the core they
exchange their on aid I think I need
that strong night to defend this should
be six is probably also a useful move
that at one point or another to get that
Bishop e3 traded Jim I'm the natural
optimist admittedly but currently I
don't see exactly how I'm losing ok I
have to recapture a g7 is a bit much
yeah I've got 95 I wasn't really sure if
that helped him 95 looks pretty decent
where I think he's bought that I think
it's brought that I've got Bishop peace
I don't really have to sacrifice the
exchange
taking on d5 then Bishop b6 that some so
I'm taking d 5 or B should be six first
let's check let's check let's give that
check check it rook chicks that's not
ideal are taking it and then takes with
a look at cell it's really activating
them so something better
maybe yeah King covering g6 let's not
some pencil is a bit a bit tricky it's
probably a position that with black a
computer would defend very easily but it
still feels a bit tricky for a human
player Bishop e7 queen bee 7 Bishop b5
takes Queen e5 rook f7 that's what I saw
and I thought that should should hold
but she's got two pawns let's got to
spawn porn actually for the piece okay
okay what's interesting probably better
in comparison rook GA dispersor really
can I don't really see what else time
morning don't see what else okay so it
takes five root create Queen f6 bit
awkward it's ready think we need seven
and down
eyes got chick here on you some that's
not again it's not so easy it really
isn't shakyas very awkward and Queen f6
Queen f7 is threatening to take then on
dzone I'd like to have some counter play
here but I don't see how that's not
possible now I'm losing that game I
don't believe it
check check check check no it's good
luck for felts on time hey yet to redraw
no I'm just winning here winning that
Roku I was just tricky I mean even
though it was completely winning it was
so tricky yeah he's got a very decent
compensation in this kind of positions
um check okay that does not work at all
but you still have to win it which which
which I fail to do so I think this is
okay it would be surprising if not but
making edge 7s already move that the
computer does not like i mean i'm giving
away you fired maybe I hoped you six of
the strong move I would still win with
Queenie form and this is I mean I didn't
like to play that move but I couldn't
come up with something else I ok I did
not really thought about this which the
engine is giving going for counter check
simply and wins now I only and here
that's really it's it's not easy here
you had the compounds to play Bishop t8
but I don't understand why that works I
saw that move I can just take that of
course I can just take that and now it
doesn't have anything meaningful I can
do this and he s just that he's got just
one check
and yeah I didn't see that and if you
don't see that you kind of have no move
check which I'm it wrong Charlie check
and Quincy 10 wins but check anyway yeah
it was that wasn't easy I mean I it's a
bit it's a bit of a shame that I didn't
when you made more timely but here
that's not it's not that obvious that i
can give away the bishop for Queenie
form and here here yet look f1 which is
stronger on Queen g5 is also very strong
rights I mean in this this type of
position it's very likely that mistake
will happen this takes will happen
Bishop taem Bishop create is a very cool
move but well as i said i don't i didn't
really have a channel didn't really see
that that i can really take and that
this is leading nowhere check with the
King running around check just about
work so check check check check yeah I
mean you have to really see that
checkmate yeah which is kind of 10 moves
team I okay well it was a bit tricky so
it's not like I'm um yeah I'm very much
depressed for not seeing it I mean would
have been would be nice but head simply
didn't okay well thanks for watching